All right.
Let's begin with last night's vice presidential
debate between Vice President Mike Pence and
Joe Biden's running mate, Kamala Harris, senator
from California.
Expectations were very high for Kamala Harris,
her experience as a prosecutor and certainly
her performances during testimony in the Senate
have been parts of.
There have been elements of why expectations
were very high for how she would do.
And she did well.
And I believe that she won the debate to the
extent that there was a winner.
But I do think that she was not nearly as
tough on Mike Pence as she was on Joe Biden
during Democratic primary debates.
I think there were missed opportunities, but
I'm going to say more about that in a little
bit.
But the big picture here, if we want to, we
don't want to miss the forest for the trees.
And the big picture is that Kamala Harris
did well on everything Corona virus related.
She did okay on economic issues.
And she was sort of so so on some other topics
which we will discuss.
But if you ask me, what will the impact of
this debate be on the election, I believe
that it is almost zero.
It's not zero, but it's very, very close to
zero because with everything going on with
Donald Trump behind in the polls, Donald Trump
releasing videos from the White House in which
he really doesn't look good, which we will
talk about.
Nothing happened in this debate that will
change the polling very much.
And that's not good for Donald Trump and Mike
Pence, because if you believe the polling
is even roughly accurate, they need something
to put them back in the lead.
And the most likely scenario is that in the
next 72, 48, 24, in the next five minutes,
some new scandal will will pop up and the
vice presidential debate will be all but forgotten.
But let's look at a few moments from it.
First of all, the fact that there even was
plexiglass installed at the last minute between
the candidates.
That's not good for Mike Pence.
The plexiglass being needed is a topic that
in and of itself is an indictment of the Trump
Penn's handling of Corona virus.
And indeed, they went right into Corona virus.
It was the first question.
I actually think this was Kamala Harris, his
best moment of the entire debate coming right
at the beginning.
Well, the American people have witnessed what
is the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our country.
And here are the facts.
Two hundred and ten thousand dead people in
our country in just the last several months.
Over seven million people who have contracted
this disease.
One in five businesses closed.
We're looking at frontline workers who have
been treated like sacrificial workers.
We are looking at over 30 million people.
Who in the last several months had to file
for unemployment.
And here's the thing.
On January twenty eighth.
The vice president and the president were
informed about the nature of this pandemic.
They were informed that it's lethal in consequence,
that it is airborne, that it will affect young
people.
And that it would be contracted because it
is airborne.
And they knew what was happening and they
didn't tell you.
Can you imagine?
So this was Carmella's best moment if you
watched only the first question or only the
first 10 minutes segment, which was on Corona
virus, and then you bailed on the debate,
you would come away with the best possible
impression of how it went for Kamala Harris.
The rest of the debate was more mixed because
Mike Pence kept going over his time, sometimes
by as much as a minute.
The moderator was unable to get him under
control.
Mike Pence would continually avoid answering
the actual question being discussed by going
back and answering the previous question or
going to questions back.
At one point it got so bad I wondered if Pence
was going to ask to spend some time on questions
from his 2016 debate with Tim Kaine.
He just wanted to set the agenda himself and
combining that with the kind of calm, arrogant
delivery that Pence is known for.
I think certainly he came up looking good
enough that his base is not going to say I
can no longer support Trump Pence because
of Pence, whether any undecideds were convinced
to the extent that they still remain much
less clear.
Here's an example of Pence doing this.
Pence asked, Why does the U.S. have a much
higher death rate than just about every other
country?
Mike Pence just talks about something else
higher than that of almost every other wealthy
country.
And you have two minutes to respond without
interruption.
And Suzanne, thank you.
And I want to thank the commission and the
University of Utah for hosting this event.
And Senator Harris, it's a privilege to be
on the stage with you.
Our nation has gone through a very challenging
time this year.
But I want the American people to know it
from the very first day President Donald Trump
has put the health of America first.
Before, there were more than five cases in
the United States, all people who had returned
from China.
So I'll spare you the torture.
But he did about two minutes of that without
actually answering.
Why does the United States have one of the
highest death rates per capita in the world
from Corona virus?
In another moment, Mike Pence was asked about
that super spreader event that they held at
the White House not this past Saturday, but
the previous one, the nomination party for
Amy CONI Barrett.
And of course, we know that that event was
at least partially responsible for multiple
instances, multiple cases of corona virus
related to the White House.
Watch pens, just bail out.
Speak up on behalf of what the American people
have done.
Vice President, since you were in the front
row in a Rose Garden event 11 days ago.
What seems to have been a super spreader event
for senior administration congressional officials.
No social distancing, few mask, and now a
cluster of corona virus cases among those
who were there.
How can you expect Americans to follow the
administration's safety guidelines to protect
themselves from Colvard when you at the White
House have not been doing so?
Well, the American people have demonstrated
over the last eight months.
They weren't given the facts.
They're willing to put the health of their
families and their neighbors and people they
don't even know first.
President Trump and I have great confidence
in the American people and their ability to
take that information and put it into practice
in the height of the epidemic.
So that is not Penn's building to some kind
of clear answer about the super spreader event
at the White House.
That's Pence ranting and raving about other
things.
And that was the entire debate.
Here is an example of Mike Pence apparently
realizing that the corona virus portion of
the debate at the beginning did not go well
for him.
Here is Pence.
Asked about presidential health and age and
disability.
And Mike Pence just says, well, I'm going
to keep talking about Corona virus.
Had a conversation or reached an agreement
with President Trump about safeguards or procedures
when it comes to the issue of presidential
disability.
And if not, do you think you should?
You have two minutes without interruption.
Well, Susan, thank you.
Although I would like to go back.
I think we need to move on.
You.
I would like to go back because the reality
is that we're going to have a vaccine, Senator,
in record time.
That was the whole debate.
I won't give you more examples of that.
Mike Pence also did some of his normal theatrically,
which include refusing to accept the science
on climate change, repeating Donald Trump's
talking about point about how forest fires
could be solved by forest management, which
they claim Democrats are either against or
aren't doing.
And then maybe the most bizarre moment of
the debate was when a fly landed on Mike Pence,
his head, and stayed there for minutes.
And the fly landing on Hypertensives Head
was funny to start with.
But the fact that it seemed to be stuck and
Mike Pence's hair gel was even funnier and
that instantly became a viral moment.
The Joe Biden campaign immediately starting
to sell fly swatters and, you know, many,
many allegories made to the biblical meaning
of when a fly lands lands on you.
For those more religious folks in the audience,
it's it's ominous.
It's not good.
But the moment that many say was Kamala Harris
is worst of the debate was when the topic
of packing the courts came up.
Now, the question came up during the Biden
Trump debate last week.
And the question is, if Joe Biden is elected
and Republicans confirm Amy CONI Barrett to
the Supreme Court, will Joe Biden pack the
Supreme Court, meaning add seats to the Supreme
Court?
And Kamala Harris, much like Joe Biden, did
not give a yes or no answer.
And there's a lot of people who are saying
it looks really bad for Kamala not to answer
the question.
I'm not so sure.
Let let me explain.
There clearly has been a strategic decision
made by the Biden campaign not to answer yes
or no about whether Joe Biden would pack the
court.
I don't think court packing is a voting issue
for many people.
So really, there's a lot of potential downside
to giving a straight answer.
And I'll explain what I mean if they say yes
or no.
They, number one, make the answer, the focus,
rather than the threat of using this in the
future.
And if you answer yes or no.
The unknown threat of maybe Biden will pack.
The court goes away.
And so I understand the risk when you decide
you're not going to answer a question.
There's a risk that you're going to appear
evasive.
But I understand the strategy because I don't
think there's much to gain by saying definitively
yes or no.
If Biden and Harris say yes, if Amy CONI Barrett
gets confirmed, we will pack the court.
The right and those on the left who don't
want the court packed will go crazy.
And that becomes the focus rather than Republican
hypocrisy about confirming Amy CONI Barrett.
With just days left before an election, if
Biden Harris say we won't pack the court,
they bail out the GOP.
And they're basically saying, even if you
confirm Amy CONI Barrett, don't worry, we're
not going to pack the court.
So while I accept that Harris didn't answer,
I actually understand why.
And it will be a question as to whether it
works or doesn't work.
But that.
But I get the strategy.
Mike Pence also during the debate, seemed
to have a fat lip and his left eye was either
bloody with a burst blood vessel or with pinkeye,
which can sometimes happen with coronavirus.
So it was impossible not to notice his physical
appearance during the debate.
It was bizarre.
But big picture, the debate was not a nothing
burger.
I think that you saw how you know, when Kamala
Harris went after Joe Biden in the primary,
you imagine there would be more ferocity and
energy from her against Mike Pence.
And I took live calls last night after the
debate, and a bunch of my callers said, you
know, sometimes when women are assertive or
aggressive in popular culture, it counts against
them.
The Martha Stewart effect, as it's sometimes
been described.
And I think that that is absolutely true to
a degree.
I still would have liked to see a balanced
approach that had Kamala Harris more on the
offensive, which we know she can do.
We've seen her do it in the Senate.
We've seen her do it in other contexts.
But the big picture is I don't think the debate
is going to change a thing.
And when the polling is looking so bad for
Trump and Pence, with now only 25 days left
until this election, they need something to
turn it around.
And this debate is not going to be the thing
that doesn't we.